so he's like there's this company it's
kind of like a cab company but anybody
can drive the cab
i was like that's the worst idea ever
why would this what are you and he was
like
let me get you this thing it's called
uber mila kunis admits she's not always
right when it comes to her husband
ashton kutcher's
business investments let me just order
it for you you can test this out and i
was like
you're gonna put me in a car with a
stranger
what is wrong with you like i was
furious at him while appearing on the
late show on thursday the actress
admitted to host stephen colbert
that there have been multiple times when
she initially thought it was a bad idea
for her husband to invest in companies
that are now
hugely successful does he come to you
and say hey honey we're going to put our
money in this
yes this happens nightly the sad part is
it happens
probably too often and the great the
best part about him is he's really smart
about including me and everything and
making sure that i'm aware of everything
that's happening he's also really smart
at knowing that sometimes you shouldn't
listen to your wife
mila also revealed that even during the
early days of dating her now husband
he would bring up business investments
including one that went on to become
one of the biggest rideshare companies
uber
so my dad in real life is a cab driver
was a cab drivers retired now and so i
grew up on
on you know on tips from from a cab
driver like that
so he's like there's this company it's
kind of like a cab company but anybody
can drive the cab
i was like that's the worst idea ever
but the bad mom star shares that uber
wasn't the only investment she thought
was a bad idea
that was first second time it was he sat
me down he's like hey babe i gotta
explain this thing to you tell me if i'm
crazy and i was like cool what is it
babe
he's like there's this thing it's like
mining for money
it's called like cryptocurrency and
there's a company called like
this is eight years ago eight plus years
ago and i was like well i think this is
a horrible idea
and he went cool we're investing in it
so he didn't listen to me i mean this
happens all the time
ashton is no stranger to great business
deals the actor has also invested in
successful companies like spotify
airbnb and soundcloud he also has
multiple jobs like not everything adds
up or i'm like what do you
really do what is this office you claim
to go to
and why are there many different
locations of this office
mila admits at the end of the day her
husband's ideas often turn out for the
best
and that praise is a sentiment she's
shared with e.t many times throughout
the years
giving props to ashton for being such a
loving husband and supportive father to
their two kids
i have a really great husband i really
do yeah no no i really do like
there hasn't been enough time for me to
be like [ __ ] pay attention like he's
still like
he's still super present
you